iraq is a total freaking mess you
probably have heard about that
a so right now ISIS which is the
islamic
state in Iraq and Syria or ISIL as President Obama is calling it, the
Islamic state in Iraq and the Lovat is
basically marching through Iraq they've
split the country pretty much into three
territories are based on you know
sectarian stop in the Sunni and Shia and
all that stuff okay I want to get to
too deep into a cover-up policy wonks
here a
but oppressor Obama said that he was
going to send any troops without that
275 troops to secure our embassy which
people are no
the Embassy in Baghdad is the biggest US
Embassy in the world there are 5,000
US citizens that work there I there may
be limited drone strikes
it's all good fun unfolding very quickly
so
again we are not experts in security but
that's why I'm doing the show to have
sort of normal people talk about the
broader issues
arm what we do saw the course right now
lol
about a big way no pressure I was just
gonna they bring in Archer
if any Dr Archer fans blow but though
that I sis figure it out tonight as
Rafferty I
dole I I don't know I don't know what to
do and I
it doesn't matter if you're listening to
a.m. talk back to top
everybody's talking about this and
nobody knows what to do
yeah so if they don't know and they get
paid to figure it out I shares yet we
are you saying that we shouldn't be
listening to the same people the
architect to the original Iraq war right
now because all those guys they're all
showing up all over the place where
that time so yeah
why is it that when they put these
people back on the cable news channels
they don't put under their names
bucked up the person yeah
lawyering but fell 6.2 expert
know it right expert exactly yeah yeah
the
so really what the what do you think we
should let me look it's a freakin this
is a disaster this could cause
this could cause I Jordan to fall also I
mean this is just the beginning
275 troops obviously maybe can defend
our embassy but can't defend a country
and does it even matter should we get
what the mall kill each other do we
exactly do we it that are
role too take care I don't think so I
don't know I was trying to read through
all the facts and I can just us just so
happy
but I do agree that we need the troops
there to protect
our people and that's why we think four
as hard as you want to save a
because he said noting that many at the
plan for me and it might have gone back
on your work but
at the end of the day I think their goal
is the goal that we should all be
worried about
protecting are people that are there
everything out I just how I wanna stay
outta
yessir Italy come back on us and then we
ran another war
so I i basically agree with you like
there's nothing we can do these
these people hated each other forever
this goes beyond us but
we did throw a bomb literally when we
went to war there
so should we to you you are with guilty
your image you are guilty conscience
lead us back into cleaning up
anything as if we even if it was
remotely possible that we could order
today
back to the old place now the leaders
are which products are and that they are
me I don't mean to oversimplify but that
the fact that I do it's lonely at the
top
you know when when we do go in were
bullies when we don't go in that were
heartless
yeah so I don't know what what makes
this situation different every other
situation
that that we've band struggling with
grief
to try to fix it or do we stay out of it
because either way we're gonna be in
trouble
yeah what you make it a good other end
may make it worse Yahoo that we're gonna
fix it might give
even a week then everyone and there's no
guarantee that will fix it it's probably
going to far worse yet what would you
guys make a general
beam in the country with C which seems
to be that we should be pulling back
from the rest of the world you know to
me like that everything happened
in Ukraine ready to talk about you going
anymore we we've sorta lost in terms of
what we said
what was supposed to happen in russia
we're pretty much 10 K
what would you think that is the general
feeling in the united states like that
we sorta don't have a role
anymore which is sorta what Obama
promised the he said we're gonna step
back
Reyna and that's what happened when I
promise don't yeah he had we want the
promise even if looked a lot better
right I think you don't get to a point
where you're fed up and like just like
we're talking right now over well we
don't think we can fix anything
why why put ourselves in a position to
make it far worse for them
Enfora is like luscious wash our hands
step away and
reading shift our focus for this thing
there we need to work on
yeah and I don't think we want to use
our resources for outside
outside problems right is there anyone
that you should watch on TV on any other
news channels that you really trust when
it comes to this is there any politician
that when they come on you feel like
they really know what they're talking
about or have you think scandal
they're all I gotta watch me good how's
the card that had a pretty good said
we're going to add there are like right
i mean is there any way that you watchin
you like this guy
really has ironically job i din when he
was running for president in 2008 before
he joined Obama
he was the one saying that there's this
country needs to be split into three
things Bay
which is crazy because everything's the
guys completely not now but I'll young
girl Joe
crazy crazy are going he was making this
point way back that never really is
there anyone that you
well then you can I say I do then I end
up looking like an idiot
because it because they they there so
let me know below their so charming and
they're just there folksy I like that
but it doesn't end up mattering I don't
know what they know what they
I only know what they want you to know
so I always end up feeling stupid anyway
I greater but
up